hey this is Pete peppers and this is a
video that's about a problem that a lot
of players have been having which is
getting through the gates and giving
friends to send them unlocks so have
been at the end of the game since level
75 so each time they add new levels I
don't get this it's just they just let
you through you don't have to get
tickets so when you're an endgame player
you don't have to deal with it and so a
lot of people have been having this
problem for quite some time and a lot of
people in our group have been trying to
help each other out and get through but
I haven't been able to recreate it
because you know I'm at the end of the
game so I have a friend who who has an
account that's at level 45 and we
decided to see if we couldn't get this
to work so I clicked on the bottles that
look like this with the empty faces on
on the map and I'm going to open it up
now
so this is the old version slips
different than it does and - far as I
remember but let's see if we can find me
yeah they're in so I'm going to send a
request just to me not to anybody else
and then click done well over here I
have my account and I can see that I got
the request now the question is is it
going to be there whenever I open up my
mailbox
but before I did this I have to say that
I cleared out my mailbox a few times
because there's always new lives coming
into alright so you can see that I have
the request and I should be able to send
it back
and down here you can see that people
just send requests so I can click on me
if you click on that
should green reloaded the mailbox so now
I have my my first ticket
I'm going to pause this for one seconds
all right so it didn't show up at first
but when I reset when i refresh the bank
it's eating my characters there and I
have one ticket to advance I'm going to
ask a couple other friends and then I'm
all I have this pause and see if I can
get those requests back as well okay so
what I did was I sent out the out the
request to different people and I'm
going to show you real quick how I did
that so I clicked on the bottles at the
gate and then brings up this again so
what I would do was I would send one to
a person close it and then open it again
and send out another one it's just a
precaution to make sure that they got
there because I know from hearing from
everybody else that they're all having
problems with this so when I came back
what I found was I had two responses in
my mailbox so you go in there you accept
these and now I have three so I can go
on to the next next level and play the
new level so there's a lot of other
things that could go wrong now I
understand this is a really frustrating
thing but that's what we've learned from
our experience in our group is that when
you send them out one at a time and you
may need to send them out more than once
that eventually you'll get them back I
really didn't have any problems here at
all so like I'm not sure if they made
some progress on it or if I you know if
it's just that simple but other things
you can try out is if you have friends
that are playing on King you can play on
King King comm just to see if you know
it works better there I've heard that it
does but when I look in there when I
look on and on on this account the
player doesn't play there often so they
don't have friends in their list to ask
so it's a little bit different um
always a good idea if you're having
trouble with requests to follow the
brain regular troubleshooting so like to
look at clearing your browser's cache
try a different browser if you're having
problems you can you know there's a
whole checklist of things you can do for
that so hopefully this will help you get
through this took not this wasn't really
hard at all for me I you know if you're
if you have a lot of requests that you
haven't been clearing out you might want
to do that find out friends who are
active that's why we you know in our
group it's a lot easier because we have
a lot of people who are playing and you
can sort of talk to them in real time
and get support for it as you go and if
you have any questions leave us a
comment please like this video share it
if you know anybody else that's having a
problem with this and subscribe to our
channel so you can get all the latest
how-to and level videos when they come
out for candy crush soda saga thanks